today we're going to talk about lambdas
we're gonna get into why this is not
going to be a programming talk really
and it's definitely not an AWS talk it's
kind of a talk about really I think
really fun and really interesting and
really beautiful theoretical construct
that allows us to simulate computation
and yeah it's gonna be kind of fun kind
of silly not practical at all so buckle
up I wrote you a poem
it goes mary had a little lamb de a
function pure as snow for every program
that mary wrote the lambda was all she
needed to know where's my thunderous
applause I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding I know it's not a very good poem
that's why I write software for a living
but this is what's cool about the lambda
and we're gonna see in a minute how it
works but basically the lambda calculus
gives us a way of representing pretty
much all computation anything that like
a Turing machine could do with just a
tiny little pure function so um the
lambda calculus oh let me zoom out so
you can see that okay the lambda
calculus and if you've seen lambda
represented as this Greek symbol that's
because that's what the name of that
Greek symbol is called you might
recognize it from the logo of every
functional programming language ever
it's basically a kind of mathematical or
perhaps logical formalism it's kind of a
system that this guy who looks super fun
to hang out with Alonzo Church is his
name and starting in the early 1930s he
started developing the system as a way
of trying to understand the theoretical
foundations of logic and math and he
fell down a like crazy big wormhole with
it and we're only gonna scratch the very
very surface of that wormhole but
there's like you could spend you're in
higher life playing with this stuff so
we're gonna spend about 40 more minutes
doing it it's as I said it's it can
serve as a universal model of
computation meaning that it's Turing
complete so no big deal
whatever we can just model pretty much
anything computable with a tiny little
lambda which we're gonna explain what
that is in a minute and just as a side
note it comes in some varieties you have
options there's the untyped variety and
simply the typed variety we're only
gonna be talking about um types lambda
calculus today okay so
oh that's tiny can we see that better
okay so um a quick note on the
difference between lambda in the Greek
symbol lambda calculus sense of the word
and lambda in the Python keyword that
you probably all know and love sense of
the word so the Python keyword is great
it's really practical we can use it in
our Python to like write programs the
lambda calculus is not for writing
programs this is why this is not
actually a programming talk it's for
thinking it's for reasoning and like
trying to understand and get to the
bottom of things and trying to make
proofs and assertions about what we know
about logic and math and those are two
very different things so let's just keep
that in mind as I said not a practical
talk you're not gonna learn anything
today that you can let go use in your
job tomorrow
so let's talk about pure functions so a
pure function is a function that has no
side effects in the lambda calculus
there is like no way no how are you
gonna have a side effect in your
function a side effect is something that
the function does that is other than
just returning its return value so for
example in lambdas in Python you can do
things like you could say lambda X print
X you could print it out to your screen
that's not returning anything useful
you're just returning none that's a side
effect and we cannot have that in
lambda calculus but it's fine with
lambdas in Python so we're gonna ignore
that feature of lambdas another thing is
that lambdas in the lambda calculus have
exactly one input it's like a pure
function that takes exactly one input
and returns exactly one output whereas
as we know in Python we can use lambda
with like multiple variables we can we
can return like a tuple of multiple
outputs so we have a lot more
flexibility there when we make a
function in both the lambda calculus and
in Python it looks kind of similar it's
just that the syntax is different so in
the lambda calculus we'd call function
abstraction the act of sort of what we
would in Python say declaring a function
in the lambda calculus if you see on the
left hand side that's represented by the
lambda symbol and then a symbol that
stands for the input variable so in this
case X then you have a dot and that's
kind of like the colon in Python between
lambda X and the body of the function
and the body of the function comes to
the right of the dot so lambda symbol X
dot X is equivalent to in Python lambda
space X colon X on board so far cool
okay if we as we said the the lambda
calculus functions can only take one
input so if we want a function that like
we want to pretend takes more than one
input we have to basically take the
first input let's say X and then return
a new function because everything is
functions return a new function that
takes the second input Y and then does
something with both of them so this the
second row after making one abstraction
there on the left-hand side this would
be a way of representing kind of a two
parameter function in the lambda
calculus would be lambda X dot lambda Y
dot body so X plus y for example and in
Python remember we have options we can
actually create a single lambda that
takes two arguments and does something
with them but here we're gonna be
restricting ourselves to just one
argument per lambda so we're gonna be
writing functions like this lambda
: lambda y : body um yeah and then once
we've got a function we've made one by
abstraction or by definition in Python
we can use it by application which is
what we would call in programming like
calling the function and this looks
pretty similar it's just got an extra
pair of parentheses on the Python side
of things in the lambda calculus
function application is just the
function that you want to apply and then
the argument you want to apply it to
with a space between them in Python we
use brackets to indicate that we're
calling something on arguments
sorry parentheses to indicate that we're
calling something on arguments okay so I
yes and I guess I didn't mention that
the lambda in Python is just an
anonymous function it just doesn't have
a name but we're gonna be cheating a
little bit we're gonna be naming some of
our lambdas just for sanity all right so
the game that we're gonna be playing
here I'm going back out is if we were to
pretend that pythons lambda was like
lambda calculus lambda what could we do
with it and as I said this is gonna be
an experimental fun silly learning
oriented talk not a programming
practical let's do useful things talk so
please take this opportunity to get off
the train if you were like want to go
learn something practical there's a
bajillion other talks on right now that
I'm sure way more useful than this one
but this one hopefully will be fun all
righty
don't worry I won't feel bad so what can
we make how about some numbers numbers
are cool we like numbers numbers help us
do things like count one thing two
things three things but what could we
count if we're in a world where all we
have is a lambda all we have is a tiny
little pure one argument in one result
out function so all we know how to do is
like create functions and then call them
apply them what could we do with that
well we could
think of applying a function as like
counting one and applying it again it's
like counting another at one and
applying it again as counting more so we
could think of counting as like counting
calls to a function our counting
function applications so if we had if we
wanted a couple of numbers zero and one
can everybody read this okay awesome um
what would those look like well okay
bear with me here we're gonna get a
little a little freaky with our
definition of numbers but if we need to
count things by applying functions then
a number is gonna need to be something
that takes a function as an input and
it's gonna return something that is
another function because everything is a
function and that function is going to
take some argument okay so if you'll
allow me here we're gonna think of all
numbers as being something that like
takes a function and returns a function
that takes an argument and does
something and the thing that it's gonna
do is apply the function f n times for
whatever number it's supposed to
represent so like one would apply the
function once and zero would apply the
function zero times exactly which would
mean we would just return X cool okay
let's see if live coding works probably
not let's find out I think I also forgot
to clear all the inputs in this thing so
that'll be interesting so to then would
be oh come on y'all help me out we
calling F twice right so it would be
like applying X F - f of X + 3 similarly
would be F of F of f of X I think look
good okay let's see what happens
now it's so far I've been asking you to
just trust me mm-hmm
but you probably want some kind of proof
so we're gonna make it we're gonna cheat
just to do some sanity checks here we
make a like a an int converter that'll
take a lambda number and convert it to a
Python int so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take the number N and we're
gonna pass it a function that adds one
to some integer I and we're gonna start
it off with the integer zero so zero
should call this function here zero
times right so that should give us zero
and one should call it once which should
add one to zero which is 1 and so on and
so forth you book you with me is this
acceptable all right let's see what
happens oh no I forgot to clear the
inputs okay so do it to zero it works it
was zero and similarly one if you
believe me I'll do it live here yeah
it's one I think you see where I'm going
with this yeah convinced you look so
convinced I have never seen a more
convinced looking group of people in my
life okay
m3 yeah whatever the same difference
okay so now how do we get a higher
number given a particular number this
would be what's called a successor
function we want we're gonna need to be
able to like take a number and see what
the next one is and in order to do that
whoa hi okay in order to do that we need
a function that takes what as input and
a number cool and gives us another
number right and a number is a thing
that takes a function oh that's not how
you spell that
and then that returns a function that
takes an X and so if I wanted just n
like the original number that I gave it
I would call it like this right I apply
and to F and then I apply that to X but
I want one more loop I want one more
application of F so if I'm not super
duper tired I should be able to wrap
that whole thing and apply F to it
one extra time I see skeptical puzzled
and completely uninterested faces okay
so let's see what happens if you believe
me here okay so four would be the
successor of three right and that should
be and is four and similarly five to be
the successor of four and I should be
able to get seven by applying like
successor to the successor to the
successor of four right three extra
successors that gives me seven
I see how excited you are by this it is
really exciting I know okay but where
can we go from here so I'm just just a
note these numbers that we have they're
called Church numerals
can you guess who they're named after
that dude from the beginning Alonzo he's
my BFF no not really but I wish anyway
so justjust if you want something to
google you can google that
okay what about arithmetic can we like
add two numbers so if we have an n loops
and an M loops and we want to add them
together we could just loop end times
and then loop and more times right so if
I had like n was 2 and M is 3 I could do
like 1 2 and then 1 2 3 and then that
would give me 5 right cool so how do we
represent that so ad is gonna take an N
and an M and it's going to loop end
times first of all so that means we
apply end to F oh sorry these is it's
gonna return a number which looks like
that
as we've seen a couple of times it's
gonna apply n to F and then to X but
then we're gonna add on a couple of
extra loops so we're gonna apply F again
M times to the result that we got from
looping end times I think this is right
everybody on board maybe we'll find out
okay let's see I don't know maybe I'm
just super tired okay so I should be
able to get this I should be able to add
eight and two and get a thing called ten
and it should convert to this all right
it worked yay nothing exploded and I
should then be able to zoom out a little
can you still read that okay I should
then be able to add them in the opposite
order and it should work and I should be
able to mess with this right like this
should give me yay yay we added numbers
good job everybody okay so um
subtraction is way harder we're not
gonna do that but multiplication
multiplication is not so hard so what
about multiplying N and M how do we do
that so basically if we're multiplying
like two times three we're gonna do like
one two that's counter one then we're
gonna do another one two and then we're
gonna do another one two and that should
give me two two two six right so we're
basically gonna loop end times M times
over okay
oh geez that's what it looks like when
you don't enter anything in cool we're
gonna fix it so multiply multiply is
gonna take an N and an M and it's gonna
give us another number which looks like
this okay so first we're gonna loop n
times and if n applied to F gives us a
function that flies F and x then if we
apply M to that that should apply that
function M times so we have like a loop
within our loop I see your faces all
look like my face look the first time I
played with this feel free to follow
along if you've got your laptop in front
of you open up an interpreter
okay so if I apply M to a function that
loops
and times then I should get a function
that loops n times M times is how I'm
trying to think about this thing let's
see what happens
all right it didn't explode does it give
this the right thing this is what I'm
expecting I should be able to multiply 4
& 3 and get 12 let's see what happens
okay and I should be able to
oops I should be able to do something
else like two int x
[Music]
let's see if it works in the other
direction
we didn't have we didn't even for math
and again dividing a super hard no more
divine ml dividing okay so what about
powers what about raising n to the power
of M huh I'm gonna take a sip of water
while you think about that one yeah
everyone looks at the ceiling like the
answer is gonna be written there okay
this one's gonna get a little weird
let's see what happens okay I want a
power function that takes an N and an M
and it's gonna give me a number right
okay let's imagine let's let's take like
a simple example let's imagine n is like
two so if I wanted to apply and like
this would be like - and it's - if I
wanted N squared I could multiply two by
two right and we saw in the last example
that that means calling like this part
this one was our M before
so imagine n was two and now we're just
now we've got like two squared okay and
then for like three it would be like
calling that again - to the power of
three so this would be like two times
two times two
imagine n is two okay
so what we're doing is we're applying n
m times to F right now if only we had a
way of telling the computer to apply a
function a certain number of times oh
wait
that's what numbers do so I should be
able to take this and get rid of these
extra things and apply em to it and this
would give me a function that calls an M
times on this function which should then
give me like the power that I want maybe
let's find out okay so this is what I
would expect right if I raise 2 to the
power of 3 I should get 8 perhaps moment
of truth
yay okay wait but I don't know maybe I
could have just faked that what if I
raise it to 4 we did it we did it okay
but um actually we can even simplify
this because this is getting ugly now
we've got like four things in here we
said a number is just a thing that takes
a function and takes an argument and
like applies to both of those we can
then just consider that if we clear all
this out since that's what the point
what a number does anyway and clear all
this out we should still have a valid
definition of the power function so
let's see if that still works okay so
that's even more elegant than like
adding and multiplication so this is
some arithmetic this is pretty fun
people are looking me like you said this
is gonna be interesting
but we but we did really really basic
math with something super complicated
isn't that what all programmers love to
do okay meanwhile I'm like hey BFF
Alonzo mr. Church sir he's like yeah
I'm John I'm speaking to you from beyond
the grave what do you want could you
tell me the answer to life the universe
and everything please we did it
we solve the computation no just kidding
but I don't know I thought this is
pretty cool because if you think about
it the way we've been taught to think
about like addition multiplication
Exponential's it's completely different
than all of this and yeah it will
totally works out in this lambda
formalism so I think that's pretty fun
feel free to disagree okay um so we've
done math that's cool but that's not all
our jobs in 2l as programmers what else
do we need
Oh
somebody said conditionals because I
planted them there in the audience
before yeah no I did it but yes we do
need conditionals and in order to do
conditionals we need boolean values
right because these sort of go hand in
hand so um oh good okay this is what
happens just ignore that the when we
when we work with a conditional it has
some kind of form like this right we say
if a condition is true and where the
condition is a boolean so it could be
true or false if it's true then we do
some stuff in the then block and if the
condition is false then we do some stuff
in the else block yes on board okay so
we kind of need to define all of these
things together so that they work out so
that we can do things like this we can
test if a condition is true and then do
the then thing and if it's not true do
that if the else thing so if then else
is gonna be a function because
everything is a function it's gonna take
a few different things well it's always
gonna take one thing but we're gonna
line up a bunch of arguments in sequence
so that it looks like it takes multiple
things so it's gonna take a condition
first of all and then we're gonna need
to tell it like a then do like a Venn
block and then we're gonna need to tell
it like an else do else block and then
something okay let's forget about what
this something is for now and go back to
boolean so boolean and I'm just naming
them true and false here so as not to
like mess with our Python words even
though the lowercase shouldn't mess with
it but anyway it's also more fun to
spell things wrong
okay so true should be a thing that when
it sits here it should pick this branch
right and false should be a thing that
when it sits here it should pick this
branch so true is gonna be a thing
function because everything is a
function that we're gonna give it a then
and an else block and it's gonna pick
the then block right just like that's
how we want to be able to use boolean so
let's just define it in terms of how we
want to be able to use it and similarly
if we give a then and an else to false
then we should get the else thing out
okay on board so far I see like one or
two knots I'll assume that applies to
everyone now what about the rest of our
if statement we didn't finish it what
we're gonna do if true and false are
like choosers here and they take a ven
and an else then we can just take our
condition which is going to be a boolean
and apply it to the then and the else
and it should choose the right one for
us if we've done everything right so I'm
going to call a condition on the then
oops apply it to the then typing is so
hard and then the else and if it's true
it should pick the van and if it's false
it should pick the house maybe let's see
okay at least our little ugly thing went
away because clearing Python notebooks
is hard let's see what happens
so I am tired that is true and the
number of coffees that I'm gonna drink
today depends on whether or not I'm
tired so if I'm tired I'm gonna drink
three copies and if I'm not tired I'm
gonna just drink one coffee because I'm
in Italy and I have to drink coffee okay
so this is what we would expect right if
I'm tired
then coffees today should give me three
yes okay let's see what happens
run okay okay all right
all right but I don't entirely believe
this because again I could have rigged
this so what if I'm not tired we did it
we programmed we programmed look at that
we have conditionals now I see you're
also excited like me okay moving on so
with truth values we can do logic that's
fun okay I'm just gonna we're just gonna
power through these kind of logic things
so in the interest of time so if I want
a not function and again I'm just gonna
use a different word so it's not to
override Python words I'm gonna call it
opposite because that's I don't know
longer anyway it's gonna take a boolean
and a boolean is a thing that takes a
Ben and an else right and a boolean
that's true is gonna choose the then and
a boolean that sauce is gonna choose the
else so if we wanted to do like opposite
day we could just switch the else in the
then and apply the boolean to it and it
would pick the wrong one because we
switched them because we're sneaky that
way do you believe me you're like yeah
okay so so we should expect this right
if I have if I make a little cheating
function that just applies a boolean to
pythons true and false just so that we
can like see what what Python thinks it
is instead of having to like do
something complicated and again this is
cheating because we can't do
side-effects and we don't have true and
false in any other way except these
functions that we created if I convert
true to boolean I should get true okay
and if I convert the opposite of true to
a boolean I should get false oh that
worked but let's make sure if I convert
the opposite of false I should get yay
okay logic step one but we need more
logic oh no we'll get to more logic in a
second first we need predicates so we
want to be able to apply a function to a
thing and get a boolean out that's like
a predicate function yeah where we we
test that something is or is not
conforming to some high standard we are
holding it to like for example being
zero so if I wanted an is zero function
that would take a number and give me a
boolean that tells me whether that
number is zero or not I could do it like
this I could apply that number which
again takes a function and applies that
function n times to a value and I could
pass it a function that takes whatever
we give it and returns false always then
if I pass that whole that end times
application of this function to true the
only time that we're going to get true
out is if we don't call this function on
true at all zero times whereas if we
call it once true we'll get turned into
false if we call it twice false he'll
still say false and so on and so forth
so I should be able to do this and get
false for two and I should be able to
try it with zero and get true on board
so we have to be a little tricky
now that we're in lambda world on how we
think about like functions like
predicates we have to start thinking in
a totally different way where where
we're thinking about the number of times
we would have to apply a function to
things to understand something about the
number of times that we have applied
that function to the thing this is why
you could like spend your whole career
thinking about this stuff we're not
going to okay similarly we could like is
another example we could have an is even
function that starts off with true
because zero will call even
and applies opposite end times
so we alternate back and forth so one is
a fault of one is the opposite of two is
false
two is the opposite of the opposite of
true which is true etc so I should be
able to get eight is even seven is not
even one is not even four is even yeah
hmm programmers ha ha ha don't clap for
me clap for Alonzo ok
we're running out of time here let's see
if we can power through this logic part
ok this is where things get a little
crazy so I'm just gonna show this to you
and let you think about it for a second
while I take a sip of water and then
we're gonna talk about it
first I have to open one
okay so this is a this is like a and
function I'm calling it both because and
is a special word and Python okay so an
operator like and or both in my case
it's gonna take two boolean trite bula
bula bula and Bobby how do we get to a
place where we can use the fact that
boolean choose either the first thing or
a second thing to tell us whether both
of them are true or one or more of them
as false hmm okay this is the answer but
let's try to figure out why
so if boules is true then I can sort of
continue and and check will be if bula
is not true then I already know that the
whole thing is gonna be false right
boule is false so if I were to set up
two things where the first thing is I
don't know what and the second thing is
false because we've hypothesized that
boule is false then false chooses the
second thing right so it will choose
false so already just by knowing that
boule is false I know that this whole
thing is gonna be false I see faces like
feel free to play with this on your own
time I think that's the only way to like
wrap your head around it okay if boule
is true though then we'll pick will be
and see what Bobby does and if will be
is also true then whatever comes here
will be like the second thing that it
would have chosen but if will be is true
then it'll choose the first thing it
won't choose this second part it'll
choose the first thing which is will a
but we already said that boule is true
so this means we'll get true I see like
one nod and a couple of like amused
chuckles okay I don't know let's try it
out maybe we can convince ourselves by
like actually applying it to stop so I
should be able to do both true true and
that should be true right
let's see what happens okay alright what
if I change it this should give me ha
it did okay what about this uh-huh
one more to check okay
are we convinced all right I'm gonna
skip these were just more examples okay
and similarly we could do like or which
I'm just gonna call inclusive or where
if boule is true it doesn't really
matter what Bobby is so boule is gonna
choose the first thing and we already
know that boule is true so we're just
gonna make it choose true and fully is
false then it's gonna choose the second
thing which is will be and then the
value of the whole thing just depends on
whether both be is true or false right
this is how truth tables work okay let's
see what happens so I should be able to
get true for this and true for this and
this should be false
haha and this should be true right yay
okay only one person is like things this
is cool so if you don't understand why
it's cool you can go talk to him later
all right yeah this was just more
examples okay I have like three minutes
left don't know how much we'll be able
to get through this but let's try oh oh
oh being flexible with me all right so
we've got some data we got like numbers
I got boolean's but what about
structures of that data could we do that
spoiler alert yes okay everybody's
favorite data structure is uh let's see
a list we live list especially in
functional programming land we love
lists right um what what is a list it's
a thing that contains stuff what kind of
stuff could it contain
so it could contain nothing
could be empty um which is often called
nil the empty list it could contain one
thing or it could contain more than one
thing yes have I forgotten any
possibilities hopefully not so we're
gonna try to represent these things by
building lists out of pairs of two
things it's gonna get a little weird but
we're gonna try to get through it okay
we're gonna have a make pair function it
takes a left thing and a right thing and
returns a pair of those two now what is
a pair of those two we're just gonna
represent a pair as being some thing
some function that takes a function and
then calls that function whatever
function you pass into it on the left
and then the right they like applies
some function to the left thing in the
right thing okay then we need a function
to like get the left thing and get the
right thing and we already have a really
nice function for choosing either the
first thing or the second thing it's
called a boolean so we're gonna take the
left the get left function is going to
take a pair and then pass the true
function to that pair which is gonna
call true on the left and the right and
true chooses the first thing so it's
gonna choose left yeah and similarly for
right so if I make a pair of one and two
and I choose the left thing then I
should get one and if this were
different okay and if this were right
okay with me cool
all right now an empty list we're just
gonna like by convention represent as a
pair of true and true and we'll see why
that's helpful for lists because we're
gonna represent lists not as a pair of
just two things but as a kind of special
pair where the first thing in a list is
going to tell us whether or not the list
is empty and then the the right thing in
that pair is going to be the actual like
of a non-empty list and if the list is
empty then we don't care about what's on
the right-hand side because it's empty
there's nothing in it so we could just
put whatever we want they're like true
that but close enough so the only type
of list that will have true as the left
element will be the empty list so we can
use for our like is empty predicate
function we can just get the left thing
in the list so is empty now should be
true okay cool um then just powering
through we can create a prepend function
which takes an existing list l takes an
item and a propensity to an existing
list l which is non empty sorry and
gives us a list which is non empty so is
empty is gonna be false the left item is
gonna be false so we're gonna make a
pair where the first thing the left
thing is false and then the right hand
side is going to be a pair itself of the
new item and the old contents of the
list see people doing like this which i
think means my chin really gets this
yeah your chin does get it okay so what
we can do then is undo that with a head
and tail function that get us the stuff
on the right hand of the list where head
is like the first thing in the list and
tail is like everything else so just
take my word for this because we're
almost out of time so okay on the first
day of year of Python I had had like one
coffee two coffees so I'm gonna prepend
to to an empty list and this is how we
get a list that just has one thing in it
so we already have the empty list we
needed a list with one thing in it this
is how we could do it we could prepend
two to the empty list so if I were to
get the head of let's say coffees I
don't know if this is gonna work let's
see this should be nope nope sorry
ah thank you haha great okay and then if
I were to prepend more stuff to that I
could get a more complicated list that
has other things so if I had coffees per
day
and I took the head of that I should get
the first thing is I took the coffees on
day one which is two i prepended one and
then i prepended three so the first
thing should be three which it is and if
I were to take the first thing of the
rest of the list that should be the head
of the tail of the list which should be
ah okay
so um we got all this stuff we got data
we've got numbers billions lists you got
arithmetic we got logic and control
whole and representing the data that we
did here is called Church encoding so
you can go google that and I know we're
like super out of time so I'm doc I'm
not going to go through these slides but
um it turns out that this what we've
been doing representing data this way is
kind of like object-oriented programming
unfortunately we don't have time to talk
about why that is but I'm gonna post the
rest of this and there's like
explanation of how that works
so I just want to say these are some
some cool places to go read more about
these things again I will tweet out the
the location of this Python notebook and
I just want to say thank you to your
research to Europe Python and to all the
people who like helped me and inspired
me to do this yeah and I would say we
thank you awesome talk really great I
learned a lot maybe I would not have
dropped out of my computer science
studies when I had such an introduction
to these kinds of things I didn't
understand it those thank you and yeah
unfortunately no time for questions but
I think she's over there you can come
grab me afterwards thank you okay thank
you again
[Applause]